imaginez une fac où vous allez en classe
pour apprendre à ne rien faire doing
nothing rien faire c'est vraiment
l'intitulé du cours c'est très sérieux
c'est l'université de Lawrence dans le
vice-conscine qui propose depuis la
rentrée ce court très spécial et
bizarrement c'est devenu le cours le
plus populaire de la fac c'est des cours
comme ça à la fac c'est le magazine
américain Times ce qui relaye l'info il
y a eu beaucoup de demandes ils sont 52
à suivre le cours et il valideront un
crédit universitaire à la fin
vous êtes mes petits caméléons
vous reconnaîtrez aisément un scarabée
qui mange une tête de mouche très
ragoutant ça vaut pas mal d'affiches de
films d'horreur mais si ça ne vous fait
pas peur encore j'ai mieux j'avais
jamais vu un visage d'une fourmi oh
c'est horrible
les enseignants qui ont créé le cours
explique qu'on est dans une société
toujours plus connectée on est surexposé
aux écrans au réseau sociaux aux médias
aux informations et finalement réussir à
vraiment ne rien faire c'est devenu
quasiment impossible on finit toujours
par traîner sur un écran et tout ça ça a
des conséquences sur la santé mentale
c'est quelle catégorie sur Jacquie et
Michel
[Musique]
je sais pas comment ça va finir mais je
sais que ça va faire mal
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit avant 30 ans
aidez-moi parce que je comprends pas et
bien votre bouche j'ai pile-poil au bon
niveau
concrètement il se passe quoi dans ce
cours pour apprendre à ne rien faire
alors la première chose c'est que les
téléphones sont rigoureusement interdits
enfin normalement
et les cours tournent autour du
bien-être on apprend à bien dormir la
qualité du sommeil la marche à pied par
exemple on vous conseille aux étudiants
de marcher chaque jour 30 minutes sans
téléphone portable et sans parler à
personne il faut s'autoriser à s'ennuyer
dire l'un des enseignants ça fait
quelques temps qu'on essaie de bosser
sur l'autonomie il faut que nos enfants
se débrouillent l'idée c'est qu'il
puisse quitter la maison assez
rapidement pour qu'on ait la paix
mon père me prier l'école privée
catholique pour pas mettre à l'école de
la cité pour me donner plus de chances
parce que et donc j'étais le seul arabe
de la classe le seul et
manger du porc à l'école
et ma mère j'ai dit maman
fais comme les autres
parti
majeur je rentre à l'intérieur je fais
tourner et je fais tourner et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va essayer de la récupérer est-ce
qu'on va la récupérer ou pas c'est un
énorme suspense prenez un papier un
stylo il est interrompre
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est l'histoire qui dans tout le monde
parle autrement chez nos amis
britanniques elles concernent Larry the
cat le chat du 10 donestre vous savez la
résidence du Premier ministre
britannique alors il y a depuis 2011 il
est connu pour comme un chasseur de
souris particulièrement redoutable mais
regardez il n'a pas hésité à cette
fois-ci à chasser un renard qui faisait
quand même deux fois sa taille
visiblement ça ne l'a pas dérangé
de carburant le trophée est arrivé comme
ça et le son est d'origine
[Musique]
la 66e cérémonie du Ballon d'Or à son
grandes surprises enflammer les réseaux
sociaux si certains ont apprécié ce
moment de transmission entre deux
légendes du foot français d'autres se
sont davantage focalisés sur la présence
de certains invités le sélectionneur des
Bleus Didier Deschamps ou encore Kylian
Mbappé on subit de nombreux tactes sur
Twitter un sport qui déchaîne les
passions des mauvaises langues Karim
Benzema et Ballon d'Or à 34 ans ses
vieux 34 ans pour un footballeur c'est
comme les chiens faut multiplier par 7
pour se rendre compte et pour terminer
ce TLS 100% Karim Benzema regardez cet
hommage au Ballon d'or sur la plage de
Fort-Mahon dans les hauts de France une
fresque géante en l'honneur de
l'attaquant du Real Madrid et de
l'équipe de France